- How have you personally
been processing it?
Just everything that's happened,
'cause there's so much!
- There's so much that yes, everything is,
no pun intended, one day at a time.
And literally, the Coronavirus
was one thing, right?
That was one thing
about us, being nervous.
It's still here, by the way.
So it's not like it's one thing.
It's just that something bigger,
something else is brewing.
And I think that with
the Black Lives Matter,
everybody who is an ally
is doing what they can,
how they can.
So whether it's protesting,
whether it's donating
to Black Lives Matter,
whether it's using your platform for it.
- Whether it's listening.
- By the way, that's the most
important thing is listening.
Is sometimes being quiet
and listening to what it is.
Listening, stop being
so defensive about it.
Black Lives Matter, period.
That's it, that's it.
There should be no anything about that.
So now it's, what are we gonna
do to make things better?
What are we gonna do to do
away with this systemic racism?
What are we gonna do to stop
these killings that are going on?
So we have to really, as
a country, come together
and really face these issues
that we've tried not to face
for so many generations.
It's time.
- So many.
- It's time, girl.
It's the perfect storm.
We're gonna be uncomfortable.
There's gonna be things
that you don't know!
- And uncomfortable is okay.
Uncomfortable is good.
- Yes, it's okay!
That's it.
And if we could just be honest and say,
"Oh, oh, shoot.
"Is that not what I was?
"Okay, let me listen, let
me learn, let me help."
But it's true.
It's a very uncomfortable time.
We just have to get into that uncomfort
and work through it,
and know that a better
thing is coming ahead of us.
- Yeah, and you have to go,
"Well, if I think it's uncomfortable,
"imagine how uncomfortable they've been
"being pushed around for years
- That's right.
- "in generations."
- That's right, exactly.
- Thank you for being honest about it
and not being afraid
to be honest about it.
I know that not everybody is comfortable
in this environment and
they lend their hand
and their money or their talent
or ears in their own ways.
But it's really important, I think,
when we do have a
platform to say something.
So thank you so much for
just being down-to-earth
and using your ears and your
heart and your platform.